das ist wirklich eine überraschende
entdeckung dazu noch ein kosmischer
rekord ein amerikanisches forschungsteam
hat jetzt ein super massereiches
schwarzes loch entdeckt neben seiner
gigantischen masse sind auch die
helligkeit und das alter dieses quasars
rekordverdächtig es ist wohl mehr als 13
milliarden jahre alt wie das
forschungsteam dem massemonster auf die
schliche gekommen ist welche mysteriöse
rätsel ist uns aufgibt und was diese
entdeckung über die entstehung unseres
universums verrät jetzt den klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
seine kennung york 13 42 + 09 28 klingt
unspektakulär doch seine entdeckung ist
umso spektakulärer es geht tatsächlich
um das fernste und älteste schwarze loch
das die menschheit je aufgespürt hat es
ist mehr als 13 milliarden lichtjahre
von uns entfernt das licht war also
tatsächlich 13 milliarden jahre
unterwegs bis es die erde erreicht hat
als das massemonster also seine
strahlung aussandte war das universum wo
sie gerade einmal 6 190 millionen jahre
jung das entspricht etwa fünf prozent
des heutigen alters entdeckt wurde das
rekord schwarze loch von einem
amerikanischen forschungsteam das in
chile nach kasan gesucht hatte ja mir ja
schon öfter einmal darüber berichtet
quasare sind quasi die kerne weit
entfernte aktiver galaxien die ein
gigantisches schwarzes loch in ihrem
zentrum haben sie zählen zu den hellsten
objekte im kosmos was bedeutet dass sie
über milliarden lichtjahre hinweg
sichtbar sind trotzdem gestaltet sich
die suche nach ihnen als sehr
kompliziert bislang sind nur rund 100
jahren bekannt die älter als zwölf
milliarden jahre sind klare lassen sich
nicht durch die aufnahme optischer
teleskope entdecken sondern durch
infrarot teleskope
der grund ihre große rotverschiebung die
spektralanalyse des neu entdeckten
fahrers ergab eine rotverschiebung von
7,54 durch dieses ergebnis konnte das
forschungsteam auf sein alter
rückschließen wie gesagt 690 millionen
jahre astronomen und astronomen
bezeichnen diese zeit als die epoche der
realisierung eine umbruchszeit des
kosmos den bis dahin neutralen
wasserstoffgas wurden elektronen geraubt
und zwar durch das sehr intensive licht
der jungen sterne dadurch ionisierte das
wasserstoffgas wie genau diese prozesse
damals abliefen ist zum größten teil
noch ungeklärt doch die aktuelle
entdeckung gibt neue hinweise auf diese
phase denn die analyse seines lichts
deutet darauf hin dass ein teil des
wasserstoffs noch neutral gewesen sein
muss das würde modelle stützen die davon
ausgehen dass die sogenannte re
ionisierung eher spät in der kosmischen
geschichte stattgefunden hat dazu die
interpretation des forschungsteams die
tatsache dass beide bisher bekannten
quasaren mit einer rotverschiebung z
größer sieben hinweise auf neutralen
wasserstoff zeigen bestätigt dass wir
sind unsere beobachtung bis in die
epoche der realisierung vorgedrungen
sind doch der masse gigant ist noch in
weiterer hinsicht außergewöhnlich nach
den berechnungen des astronomie teams
setzt der quasi rund 40 billionen mal so
viel energie frei wie die sonne und zwar
pro sekunde die analyse des
amerikanischen forschungsteams ergab
aber nicht nur dass es nicht nur sehr
hell sondern auch sehr massereich ist
genauer soll es rund 8 800 millionen
sonnenmassen anfassen unfassbar wenn man
das beispielsweise mit dem schwarzen
loch im zentrum der milchstraße also
unserer galaxie vergleicht das hat
nämlich nur knapp vier millionen
sonnenmassen und diese gigantische masse
stellt die forscherinnen und forscher
für ein großes rätsel
denn mit unseren bisherigen wissen lässt
sich nicht erklären wie das damals noch
so junge universum ein solch
massereiches schwarzes loch produzieren
konnte die berechnung könnten also
darauf hinweisen dass frühe schwarze
löcher
doch schneller wachsen als bislang
gedacht doch das ist nur eine vermutung
die entstehung solcher massereichen
schwarzen löcher ist und bleibt wohl
erst einmal eines der größten rätsel der
astrophysik doch trotzdem haben schon
die ersten analysen des quasars super
spannende informationen über die
frühzeit des kosmos geliefert das ziel
der forscherinnen und forscher ist es
jetzt weitere außergewöhnliche quasaren
zu entdecken dies könnte zukünftig mit
sensibleren instrumenten als bisher noch
ein
engagieren wenn ihr kein video zu
schwarzen löchern und da gibt es immer
wieder welche uns auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann sollten wir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen
nicht dem auf die glocken und dann
verpasst er kein video geht es weiter
mit dafür draufklicken dunkle materie
rätsel löst spielen schwarze löcher eine
rolle
eine sehr spannende these und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran